so today I want to talk about how this
amazing exercise makes you live longer
okay first I want to explain what HIV is
HIV heart rate variability it's a test
that you can get done that actually can
predict your mortality from heart
attacks
I used to use in my office all the time
and you can pick up some real
interesting information have you ever
heard of the long-distance runner who
crosses the finish line and drops out of
heart attack and they don't look like
they're unhealthy it's because they had
poor heart rate variability so let's
just explain what this is it's over time
the heart beats it contracts and relaxes
and you're using the sympathetic nervous
system contract and the parasympathetic
which is relaxation constantly boom-boom
lub-dub lub-dub so let's say for example
your heart rate is 60 heartbeats per
minute okay now you would think that
each beat is exactly one second but it's
not the distance or the time period
between the beats she normally should be
varied so this one might be 0.8 seconds
this one might be 1.1 seconds this one
might be 1.3 seconds this might be point
7 seconds so they're all varying and
that's actually a normal healthy body
it's when they're the same exact time
frame is where you become very very
unhealthy interesting very contrary to
ative but the more varied that heart is
the greater the ability of it to adapt
to things the more flexible it is but if
it's the same over and over it's very
rigid and it doesn't recover that well
let me just use another diagram right
here let's say for example you started
exercise you activate the sympathetic
nervous system okay and then at some
point you stop exercising when you stop
exercising the parasympathetic nervous
system which is the recovery system
actively kicks in and actively pushes
that pulse rate down
okay so we have this nice balance of
sympathetic and parasympathetic going on
especially in the heart other parts of
the body there are different ratios but
I'm gonna use the heart as an example so
we really want to align our exercise
based on intervals based on our
heartbeats based on this right here we
don't want to do this sustained exercise
for a long period of time it's much
healthier to exercise in waves or
intervals as in high-intensity interval
training so I recommend that you do
short bursts of high-intensity with a
good amount of rest and then do that
over and over and over because that'll
be very very healthy for your
cardiovascular system and it can extend
your life span and one of the reasons
for that is this most people have a
weakened recovery system a weakened
parasympathetic they're heavy on the
sympathetic system the stress and very
weak on the recovery system right here
and so I had a patient by the way that
she exercised and then her pulse rate
was like like 150 it's pretty high she
comes in the next day it's still at 150
I'm going what the heck is going on here
she has like no recovery I tested her
and like there's no recovery going on so
there's nothing to push the pulse rate
down so a really good test to measure
recovery is to do heart rate recovery
testing and just to measure your pulse
rate after a minute of exercise and see
how fast it comes down if it doesn't
come down fast then you have a problem
so any time you exercise you want to
work with the both systems and not
overdo it
it's definitely on this system right
here so short bursts of high intensity
of exercise and I'm only talking like
one to one and a half minutes and then
you lie yourself to rest for maybe two
or three minutes back and forth and you
can even apply this to any exercise like
for example where I write my bike I will
go really hard for a period of time and
I'll coast for a while and ride lightly
and then do it hard back and forth you
don't want to do sustained anything for
a long period of time
that actually works against the heart so
as far as health goes and cardiovascular
flexibility interval training is by far
the better option
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it